hey guys just see that I'm Jenna we're
doing a freaking podcast I cannot
believe it
yeah I do because this is a 15th time
we've done this intro so I gotta here
not ensure that we're doing it but I'm
pretty excited we don't know what this
is gonna become or if it's ever gonna be
anything or ever gonna do it again do we
even have a news made we even have a
name for this podcast that I was
thinking in my small mind and that would
be do I do we say it or do we maybe let
them pick or do we just pick or do we
just we can always like talk about it
and see if they like it and we see if it
sticks
yeah we were thinking the same brain
same brain well I was thinking it and
now you're thinking it because a lot of
the times we'll do things like it the
other day you tweeted something about
sweatpants and I picked up my phone to
tweet the same exact tweet and
thankfully I saw your tweet before I
tweeted between yeah I tweeted I wonder
what's what pins I wear today because
you know we've been bored in the house
and in the house bored wearing nothing
but sweat pants so I'm you know what
there's been a lot of times well I'll
tweet something and then I'll be like oh
you tweeted this one yesterday
and I know and a lot of times we'll
shoot and a lot of times we'll shoot
video are we gonna be editing this ah
light editing editing don't mess up
don't mess up don't mess up okay yep
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't remember doesn't matter this is
a memory test because I wanted to test
out what would be like to record a
podcast on an iPad and I think this is
probably a setup that we have right now
which would be better for a legal Walton
person kind of recording on the iPad
there's probably some ways to do
multiple inputs into the iPad but I mean
you look another dongle there's
definitely a way to do it
but I just wanted to make do with what
we had and I really wanted to try out
this new magic keyboard for the iPad it
is so awesome it is way cooler than I
thought it was gonna be it is pretty
cool you're kind of flexing on us a
little Hans Erickson I thought I mean
I've I'm you know I don't know look at
this you can't because this is audio
unless you're watching the video wow
she's lexing her muscle I can't lift up
my other arm because I hurt myself after
doing two years of jiu-jitsu I never
hurt my shoulder guess what I did in
quarantine hurt my shoulder my shoulder
has been injured for 12 years since my
volleyball days so any time I'll do like
any like presses it's like does this
like popping and it kind of sounds like
when you snap a rubber band like that's
what it feels like so you know what we
can do mm we can insert a sound of a
rubber band snapping oh did you guys
hear that
I felt it that's it so one thing that
Justine said that is an essential part
of a podcast our mugs we have to have a
mug so we don't have anything to put in
our mugs and for the people who are
watching the video we here have our mugs
but the problem is we usually drink
these yerba Mattei drinks so I was like
well why don't we just put you can
inside the mug and this will be but you
guys missed the biggest dilemma that we
had because the dilemma was which side
of the table we're gonna sit on because
I wanted to know what side Jenna's well
okay wait I which hand Jenna would be
drinking the mug from so like who you
don't know how to do I think she was
like okay walked in this mug and pick it
up like you're gonna pick it up and I
was like so you want me to pick it up
like I'm gonna pick it up give it I'm
gonna pick it up but like I'm thinking
and lickable which hand would it be and
I'm right-handed so we just kind of felt
natural to pick it up with my right hand
also there's a lot of echo in this room
and I'm well aware of it this is
honestly just a test
this is this is version one this isn't
Faiza
it's a beta test of small brain it is
we're learning it's my thought of a same
brain seemed very good I just I don't my
brain is quite large okay your brain is
my brain is large I am an intelligent
human being so listen yourself I just
want to go outside and every time I go
outside even just to walk to the dog it
feels like I'm doing something wrong it
feels like I'm committing a crime even
if I'm not around a single person it
feels weird it does feel weird like I
went to the grocery store like waited
outside in the line which I actually
prefer because it was like what three to
three weeks ago I was waiting in a line
where it was backed to the back of the
store and you're just surrounded by
these people so I actually think it's
interesting now is this gonna be the new
normal for when things do go back to
normal are we gonna be waiting outside
nursery stores in lines easy it makes
sense I saw that Delta is now allowing
passengers who are at the back of the
plane to board first because it makes
sense it does make sense it makes sense
so I'm just wondering like what is the
future gonna be like after this are we
gonna go back to these not so smart ways
and I don't know I think that it'll
never be the same ever again well at
least as long as like we're around
because we know what it used to be like
but obviously people that are born now
they're never gonna know what it was
like well that's like we don't know what
you know like the Great Depression and
things like that were like we don't know
but researching that and reading about
it don't do it no haven't already
because a lot of the things that have
happened in the past are kind of going
to definitely resurface but either way I
don't want to talk about that because
it's depressing I don't really know what
happened and it's hard not to talk about
it is because it's such a huge part of
everything that's going on it's
completely changed all of our lives and
honestly the reason that I've been using
my iPad I feel like it's because I have
like this whole new kind of way of life
I guess because I'm used to traveling
and I thought that I use my iPad a lot
when traveling I've been using this
thing so much it is nice it's great like
oh I love it anyway I don't own an iPad
what I'm not I'm not sure I'm gonna be a
lot of this podcast anymore but I'm
sorry well you can use this
one and I allowed to talk about
something else or nothing what do you
mean well cuz I have the surface pro X
but I've just been using that like to
carry around the house to watch Netflix
and different shows you can because I
mean you know it has a little trackpad
which is why when I went to do this this
older keyboard not having a trackpad
really threw me off yes what has a
trackpad
I love the iPad I just did new iPad
magic keyboard my stomach has rumbled
I'm sorry did we just eat three hours
ago here's the thing I'm eating dinner
and I'm already thinking about what I'm
gonna have for breakfast exactly and if
I'm having dinner I like I will be
thinking about dinner tomorrow like
because I don't want to eat the same
thing after dinner today I had an
incredible dinner last night it was
risotto and like roasted cauliflower so
I need to give you my cauliflower recipe
Oh parently now and this pandemic I've
become a chef because behind the Bravo
oven the bouquet it's true that's kind
of like cheating is cheating but yeah
like this cauliflower
it's the florets that I get from Whole
Foods and I put some olive oil in a bowl
I put some garlic powder some paprika
and some salt and I just mix it all up
and I put it in the oven and it is
perfect do you like jalapeno it all do
you explain okay well I got some
jalapeno olive oil I'm 95 now it's
absolutely incredible I was making some
eggs with it I also toasted a little
toast in a frying pan host oh man I am
learning to be oops I hit the table oh
gosh eat okay I did not touch the table
watch the table are you you're touching
the table with your leg you're touching
the table with your leg Jenna but my
life hasn't been you're talking pity it
doesn't matter have oh my gosh oh my
goodness okay so this is going
moderately well how long have we been
recording it feels like five years does
it feel like five years where's the
timer that tells me how long - recording
hey iPod I don't want to touch anything
because I might mess it up normally if I
did this on my macbook I would record in
logic but I really wanted to try to do
this as simple as possible we plugged in
the microphones and hit record we did
have to do a couple of takes
so you went with the right hand huh
mm-hmm I can't I think that lugs should
have this on both sides like the handle
on both sides cause like what if what if
what if I want to just really I don't
know hold on I have something for you
I had a sniffle I'm so sorry that's how
I do season as well and my allergies
have been just a nightmare
are you sure it's allergies yeah I'm
positive it's allergies but he's long
I've lived with allergies for 30 years
and every time in the spring 30 where's
my marker jesse has stood up which makes
me very excited to talk about I bought a
new Dyson air purifier for my allergies
it's nice it's not hairy No
and I forgot to forgot I might have put
my address wrong so I should call them I
also ordered a logitech camera but I
can't find the information of what email
I used anyway Oh hold on for the viewers
who are just on the audio Justine has
come back into the scene she has a
sharpie marker this is a what I wanted I
don't know if this is what I wanted I'm
not sure but we're gonna try so Jenna
has a hashtag mug I do yeah this is the
reason that I asked you what hand you
write with or not are you write with
which hand you would use your mug with
right hand so that I could write your
name on it mmm
do we need mugs nothing so have you
thought my name wrong I did it but this
is smudging because it's not this is not
good so don't touch the the front of it
okay this is really quality content I
promise
no I'm not gonna promise I was gonna
promise them that set the mug down you
said I had to be gentle
something I'm gonna promise them for the
next one would be better but honestly
let's just I've talked about very very
interesting things I've talked about
technology I've talked about current
events I've talked about how's your
eyesight am i okay oh you know what
another relative another relative
relative relative relatable Jenna's
relatable another relatable topic vision
I have been doing nothing but staring at
screens I'll wake up I'll look at my
phone
in tenders which I'll go to my computer
I'll go to another tablet I'll look at
my TV before bed same thing so in the
gaming gaming monitor my eyes have been
hurting I had a migraine the other day
like it was so terrible and and it was
definitely because I've just been on
screen exactly it's more really really
bad so I am iPhone I have one of the
invisible shield screen protectors that
blocks out the blue light but I'm like
everything else I know well a lot of the
phone like even the new one plus one has
the blue light blocking and the monitor
that I have also has a blue light
setting as well so yeah there's a lot of
which one it's the the razor one oh
that's smart I love this razor so this
monitor is so cool because I have three
inputs I have a USB C going into my iMac
pro I have it going into the DisplayPort
going into my PC and then I have the
HDMI for Game Capture so that goes into
my Xbox or Nintendo switch it's so great
that's pretty aggressive people love
multiple monitors but I don't
well now that I'm a streamer Genesis one
stream thank you very much I have been
using the the one LG monitor for the
games and then the other one for like
monitoring the chat and then I had my
macbook which is powering it all through
the elgato and then the but it's it was
a lot to look at so not only am I
looking at one screen I was now looking
at three different screens so I guess if
I was doing streaming and stuff it makes
sense but on this monitor you can also
do the picture-in-picture
so I would have in the corner I would
have like my Mac or my PC in the little
like one of the corners so that I can
see if I had to hit record or stop but
now I also have the iMac kind of sitting
next to my computer it's like kind of
recessed down my little setup looks like
a spaceship it does I sit down I like
push one button in the light Elgato the
lights come on I'm like John you know we
were on some zoom or conference calls
together well I was in my space and
you're on yours and I was like whoa she
looks cool what else should we talk
about well what can we talk about do we
talk about the weather it's been finally
very very nice and lost
hot in this room right now little sweaty
I'm super sweaty but it's been the
weather's been weird we had like a week
full of rain it's been chilly but now
it's a nice I went outside yesterday and
I was trying to go for a run but it's
really hard to run with the facemask
yeah and then I thought am I gonna get a
tan line from the face mask
yeah doesn't matter no one's gonna see
it actually they've gotta make videos
yeah cuz like wait a minute that's also
a thing I've quit caring as much like
you know what I don't think I'm ever
gonna get a manicure again oh I'm gonna
do my nails later they looked so bad
they're really bad I'm gonna give myself
a manicure and I bought that like gel
kit I don't think I'm going to you're
not because I have it let's do it yeah I
definitely like that whatever it is some
gray here
gray hair here that's hard thing to say
yeah let's not talk about it cuz I don't
know about mine either don't look I am a
natural blonde yeah okay but no I'm not
like people have seen my haircolor be
like light and dark like it's whatever I
would like to talk about animal crossing
though for a minute before we take this
before we close out our first podcast
that we just basically are saying
something oh look I have an email you
have an email hi Justine no no this is
my iPad now sorry she has given it to me
animal crossing hi hours have you long I
don't know but the thing is I don't
think that I have the ability to make
these crazy beautiful islands like
everybody has do seems insane no I came
over this morning to sow my cherries and
I'm like has she done anything else no
you have like these paths but were those
like custom stone designs so you unlock
terraforming after cake a slider comes
in performance at your Island I just got
cake a slider mentioned by Tom Nook oh
my god I hit my microphone mic so new
horses
I need like a protective bubble like
that like yeah so um I'm just said we
have to set up a campsite my first
visitor just came today am I supposed to
see the crime site yeah my sister say hi
to use the amiibo no no you have to talk
to them well I didn't they've been here
all day I have
to them yes everybody like you know made
fun of me when I was obsessed with
amiibo okay do you okay 500 of them you
don't need 500 yes what people can't get
now you can't get the Animal Crossing
amiibo cards and they're extremely
expensive but what about the other 450
ones you guys don't work with a game but
you're right it's completely unnecessary
gosh don't want to say that I have an
addictive personality but I'm gonna have
to say I do you definitely I mean it's I
get it because I'm addicted to sugar me
too that's the one thing that I'm trying
very hard not to be I'm not trying very
hard at all I love you no but okay so
going back to the amiibo you take the
amiibo and they you can invite those
amiibo characters to your Island because
we got the Animal Crossing ones like I
can't have Mario come to my Island
no but I think that you can actually
invite them maybe no that's cuz you have
you gone to harvey's Island yet yeah
didn't it was weird it was a little I
felt real I felt like I was about to be
violated like this is like a me-too
story waiting like I felt super
uncomfortable and I left he's like
coming tomorrow he's like hey this setup
right here sit on the couch and I'm like
it was a little weird it was like
absolutely not I'm a strong independent
woman and I'm gonna leave this special
office I'm comfortable and I've never
returned I never returned either but
I've seen a lot of really cool stuff
because you can basically use any props
you can invite other amiibo you can
invite other friends there yeah that's
what he was telling me and I was like
you want me to bring my friends you want
me to subject my friends to this
behavior was like I'm not coming back
I'm didn't do it I never came back
though see same brain but some of us
make better choices others yeah anyway I
am I'm sweating I'm starting to see
floaters I think cuz I'm feel like I'm
gonna pass out
my gooey chocolate my shoulder it feels
inflamed now when I touch it it's
hurting we'll stop times what do you
think it is did I hurt myself yes you
know as you get older some shyness
injuries are more prone to happen I mean
I was just doing a yoga class look don't
I wouldn't admit that you say you were
like well it was the sculpt class with
weights okay that's that's like a more
intense yoga class I just bought boxing
myths and boxing gloves and pads so you
have to heal up so I can fight you I'm
so into that jab we guest are doing Muay
Thai jab jab cross please please let the
audience know I am jab jab crossing
genna's jab jab crossing jab jab cross
okay oh no much did you ever see it's
the makes hole fight camp no have you
seen that huh it's like app boxing
basically but it has like a big like
stand-up punching bag and they're
sensors in the gloves this is something
I could have in my home yeah you you
have it like you don't have it I don't
have it no I don't but I've been looking
at it because I want to boxing well
there's an app but there's also like a
big stand so it all connects together
yeah it's pretty cool I'm gonna be doing
some one later
tell me about boxing lighting in a video
has to be I have to become a fighter
because Justine we don't know what's
gonna happen the apocalypse is basically
happening what if this turns into like
you know fight or flight I didn't get a
fight I'll ground fight you can start
striking striking one day this is a
funny story I was Jenna was sitting at
the desk I was setting up the lights and
stuff and I turned it on why well first
I said striking I go what does that mean
as I look up and then I get flash banged
with like the brightest light ever I'm
like okay I learn with that man you go
why didn't you tell me you were gonna
turn it on I said strike that striking
okay I'm turning the lights on yeah that
was a mistake home yeah ever not it
mm-hmm
no I'm like traumatized every time
you're like striking I'm like no don't
get me don't streaking striking striking
god
just wanna be feeling Animal Crossing
right now me too I'm looking at my
switch I can't see it I know it's like
I'm salivating about it turn up see
other day at our friend Howard's Island
for what was like 480 here's the problem
oh don't even get me started on the turn
up scam that drippy nose I have a drippy
nose right now what is what is the
what's the name I can't even think okay
anyway either way walking around
sneezing and nose drips eternal greatest
hog life and I bought them for like 100
and something Belles and then the rest
of the week on my island they were like
40 bells 38 bells
50 bills wouldn't draw bells and you see
the ants no I don't have ants I'm clean
I put my trash I recycle it no no you
leave the the rotten turnips out and
then you get ants why don't we want ants
because it's so cool they're cut a
snapping turtle yesterday I'm so jealous
my god no I'm not oh my gosh I was like
it was one of those moments but you're
like do I really want a fish and I was
like no but it was big I'm like I should
get it and it was a snapping turtle I
was like oh my gosh this is incredible I
am so glad that the egg day is over a
funny day oh my god the first couple of
days I'm like this is so cool and then
if I have to shoot down one more
freaking balloon and it's not furniture
and it's a freaking egg I was losing my
mom and I was doing the fishing
tournament and I can't get getting a
fish oh no crap I was like they should
at least have it set so like if you're
doing a fishing competition no eggs
oh don't even so don't very-very I put
it in I feel traumatized all right I
think we're done now I sweat honestly I
could keep talking probably for quite a
long time but since this is just a test
to see what this looks like what it
sounds like I know there's audio things
that I need to do but I'm not doing it
now cuz this is a test
this room is echoey I need to put maybe
like some felt on the bottom of this cup
my nose is runny for my allergies we're
also getting a lot of cross audio on
each mic so there's some things we need
to do and I'm aware of it so feel free
to leave us any comments in
ever I don't know if you're listening to
this how you'll send us a tweet us if
you're watching this on youtube you know
how to use it I feel like I see most
things on Twitter responses me too
at Jenny's Eric at iJustine cuz I'm like
I just scroll through Twitter all day
long I get all my news from Twitter
aye-aye-aye like - I don't know
something also that's interesting is now
that everything is sort of shifting to
digital like I have a lot more time from
not having to like drive to meetings
everyone just does it on zoom or does a
call like that's a lot more practical it
really is one time we had a meeting in
Burbank and it literally took me eight
hours of my day for a one-hour meeting
because it took me like an hour to get
ready 45 minutes to get to your house an
hour and a half to get to Burbank an
hour for the meeting and then took me
three hours from Burbank to my house
because it was like traffic so I don't
know if that was actually eight hours
but because yeah it's kind of crazy how
much time we're saving and how much time
I'm wasting playing him crossing you
have to play war zone with me you know
what time of my life I've been playing
every night with my friends for the past
three weeks I'll play and then I start
getting tired or hungry and then I have
to go eat or I have to like harvest or
something I don't know I keep hitting
this we do we read dinner and then we
all meet up around like seven o'clock
and we play for a couple hours and then
we go to bed oh so I'm invited now they
have quads so you know we've got space
for you she's watching her own YouTube
video I just got up oh god I am alright
okay that's it thank you so much for
listening thanks for watching or
listening or however you're consuming
this piece of
I have to go I have allergies okay
bye-bye now we're gonna get stop going
to stop